we are no one we are everyone and we are
invisible we convinced ourselves that
they were gone but they were just
hibernating
they came for everybody oh please
obviously
I guess we have ourselves for reckoning
[Applause]
what are you two talking about oh
nothing just the end of the world hi
everyone its charlie HBO just dropped
the first official trailer for the
watchman TV series that's gonna start
airing episodes this fall so I'll
explain what's going on when it's
probably actually going to premiere all
the Easter eggs and imagery most of you
either read the comics or you saw the
movie so you have a broad familiarity so
if you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos
obviously this is an airing episodes to
the fall but there'll be another big
trailer at Comic Con and then we'll
learn a little bit more about what's
going on with the series it'll be really
good solid series to tide us over in
between Game of Thrones prequel seasons
because the Game of Thrones prequel
won't start airing episodes till
sometime next year
but this is taking place thirty thirty
five plus years after the events of that
movie it said in present day but it's in
the obvious alternate history where dr.
Manhattan left into self-imposed exile
then eventually at the end of that story
they found Rorschach's journal so they
learned the truth of what Adrian beat
Ozymandias had done but you get the idea
it's kind of this darkest timeline
because of what happened with dr.
Manhattan and superheroes so at the
beginning of the trailer you see the
cult of Rorschach's it seems pretty
clear that they're learning from
Rorschach's journal the words that are
scrawled behind them in the church where
they're having their meeting there is
Psalm 65 it says praise waiteth for the
Oh God in Zion probably a reference to
dr. Manhattan because obviously he's the
most important character in the series
but as of the end of the Watchmen comic
book he leaves earth to go into
self-imposed exile if you're a big comic
book reader there is an explanation for
where he goes and what he's doing but
because the Watchmen comic books are
part of the DC comic book universe
I think this Watchmen TV show is only
going to be drawing from Watchmen canon
and it won't be doing any of the DC
comics crossover stuff so if you've been
reading Geoff Johns Doomsday Clock
Watchmen storyline I don't think they're
gonna be doing any stuff like that like
Superman isn't gonna show up and face
off with dr. Manhattan even though that
would be a badass series to watch Henry
Cavill Superman Duke it out with the dr.
Manhattan even though dr. Manhattan is
way more powerful than superb and if
you've forgotten the original ending of
the story so the comic book ending is a
little bit different from the ending in
the movie but in the comics Ozymandias
wanted to get
the people to start hating dr. Manhattan
instead of just worshipping him like the
God that he was he wanted to get dr.
Manhattan to leave Earth of his own free
will so in order to get the public to
turn against him he summoned a massive
Leviathan to destroy New York City a
whole bunch of people died and he found
a way to make the disaster look as if it
had been caused by dr. Manhattan his
plan works
dr. Manhattan had become so dissociated
with the human condition that he
couldn't identify with people anymore so
he goes off to explore in the universe
in alternate dimensions you have to
imagine that his powers continue to
evolve he can do pretty much anything
you can imagine he can manipulate
reality on the molecular level so he can
travel between dimensions
[Music]
what happened was though is that
Rorschach found out what Ozymandias was
doing inserted writing about it in a
journal as he was studying him he wasn't
able to stop the disaster but the
journal which he wrote all of his notes
and his evidence and was sent to a
newspaper the newspaper published his
journal that probably led to the
development of this Rorschach cult so
like at the end of the trailer Don
Johnson's character says oh nothing's
happening it's just the end of the world
he talks about a reckoning that's coming
doomsday is coming you also see a lot of
clocks counting down to midnight in the
trailer clocks are very important
iconography in the story of Watchmen so
I'll explain what the clocks mean in a
second too but effectively the reckoning
they're talking about is the public
learning the truth of everything in
being open revolt because before the end
of the watchmen comic book series what
happened was is that superheroes in
costume vigilantes had been outlawed
unless they worked on the side of law
enforcement so you can see Regina King
dress up in a vigilante uniform and
pummel the crap out of someone but she
puts a sheriff's badge on so it's almost
as if she's leading a bit of a double
life but remember that anybody that
wants to be a vigilante has to be a part
of the police department so we'll see
what's going on with her character
because based on her age in this she
would have been a little girl during the
events of the original Watchmen story
before dr. Manhattan left Earth you also
see Tim Blake Nelson scare achter he's
also a bit of a psychopath a comedian
type character but he's a police
interrogator so I'll explain him in a
second too the reason why clocks are
important is because within the original
Watchmen story there's this clock that
they show between each of the chapters
which is slowly counting down to
midnight and it's called the Doomsday
Clock the Doomsday Clock will run out
when Ozymandias disaster will happen so
doomsday is that big Leviathan event in
the comics obviously on the TV show was
more of a bomb meant to mimic dr.
Manhattan's energy signature but it's
the same basic idea
[Music]
so when you see all the different clocks
in the trailer counting down to midnight
is sort of like they're counting down to
another doomsday that's happening again
because the theme of the series is is
that nothing ever really ends Don
Johnson's character says they're getting
ready for another reckoning just people
learning the truth of everything so it
all sounds like it's building towards
the return of dr. Manhattan God coming
back to Planet Earth the other reason
why clocks are really important to the
Watchmen series or because dr.
Manhattan's father was a watchmaker who
had talked him about the importance of
time he says if time is not true then
what purpose have watchmakers when he
gets into the accident that gives him
his powers right before his body gets
ripped apart he pulls a pocket watch out
of his pocket and says good as new then
later at the end of that chapter you see
a pocket watch on the old cover of a
Time magazine in it's frozen at the
exact moment that the atomic bomb hit
Hiroshima so it's no coincidence that
you see someone pull out a pocket watch
during the trailer and you see these
other clocks counting down even at the
end of the trailer where they show the
HBO logo the watchman logo you see the O
in the HBO gets stuck in the 5 minutes
to midnight position as if it's getting
ready to hit that doomsday time in this
shot it seems like Don Johnson's
character is the captain of the police
department because it's 35 years later
and Jeremy Irons is playing an older
version of awesome man Diaz it's
possible that some of these other older
characters are older versions of
vigilantes from the original Watchmen
series but we'll see
but he's addressing them saying that we
thought that these people were gone but
they were just hibernating he's probably
talking about the cult of Rorschach
because they're fighting them later in
the trailer you see this monument that
looks at the Washington Monument but
it's been changed and it looks a little
bit more like dr. Manhattan's hydrogen
atom symbol if you don't know why dr.
Manhattan tattooed that symbol on his
forehead is actually the depiction of a
hydrogen atom he says that he admires
its simplicity so he adopts it as his
iconography is sort of his hero symbol
you get a better shot of Regina king in
her vigilante uniform the name of her
character is Angela Abraham in her
character description just reads
fiercely intelligent unapologetically
independent her style is inspired by Pam
Grier in Angela Davis in her Ryu Murr
and wit stand out hard to pin down as
she wears many masks mother why
and a cop she grew up religious but has
abandoned spirituality for pragmatism
she's somewhat guarded and fiercely
protective of those she loves Tim Blake
Nelson scare achter is called Looking
Glass and he's obviously a vigilante -
working for the police department his
character description makes him sound
like kind of a psychopath so it says a
good-looking cop the native Oklahoman
isn't simple as his rural accent makes
him appear to be a top interrogator and
behavioral scientist he may also be a
bit of a psychopath it literally says in
his character description that he might
be a psychopath so when you see him
standing in front of all these changing
backgrounds it seems like he's trying to
interrogate someone as part of this
Rorschach cult that they're trying to
take down but when Don Johnson's
character talks about we thought that
they were gone and they flash back to
this scene here at the carnival with all
these dead people this seems like it's a
flashback to Ozymandias disaster at the
end of the original Watchmen comic book
then you see a much older version of
Ozymandias meditating in a fortress that
seems in a very remote area you see a
picture of him pushing down on a device
here like he's activating something
Jeremy Irons is fantastic so I think his
take on this character will be really
cool you see Don Johnson's police
captain character facing off against
what looks like the cult of Rorschach's
who light up this big field and then
start firing giant guns at them Jeremy
Irons Ozymandias character rides by on
horseback past a flag that looks like
his right out of tales of the black
freighter which was the comic book
within a comic book
the original tales were the black
freighter stories that would appear in
the Watchmen series were just an ancient
tale of things playing out in a very
similar fashion to what was happening in
present day if you have the ultimate cut
of the Watchmen movie they actually
added the cartoon tales of the black
freighter to that so you can actually
watch that entire thing play out
[Music]
delirious from nearly drowning I saw it
the black freighter hellbound ships
black sails against the yellow Indies
sky this hooded character climbing out
of the police transport seems like it's
supposed to be pirate Jenny played by
Adelaide Clemens the funny thing about
her character's name is that it was
actually taken from a song that inspired
the tales from the black freighter
miniseries that appeared in the original
Watchmen comic book but the character
description just reads an androgynous
and lustful bisexual cop Jenny is an
anarchist at heart so it sounds like you
have a lot of crazy people working as
vigilantes for the police department the
whole idea with the Watchmen comics
series is that a lot of the superheroes
are just as crazy as some of the
villains like you have the comedian you
see a family outside looking up in the
sky this seems like there's a ship
crashing through the brush in a
different scene it seems like the
original a low ship so we don't know if
that's them just invoking more things
from the original Watchmen series we
don't really know what's going on with
al man 2 during the course of this but
he would be another really old person
too if he were still alive but like I
said I think the series is building up
towards the eventual return of dr.
Manhattan so if you've been reading the
Geoff Johns Doomsday Clock storyline
that's those of a story about Ozymandias
engineering a plot to get dr. Manhattan
to come back but like I said I think the
HBO series isn't gonna be pulling from
any DC Comics stuff it's all there's
gonna be core watchmen al and more stuff
if you're wondering while the police
have those yellow masks on - one of the
big things about the original series is
that police got really upset at costume
vigilantes because they hid their
identities allowing them to continue to
lead normal lives during the day
whereas police could not do that so it
seems like in present day the police has
started to adopt their tactics by hiding
their faces making it easier for them to
police the public without fear of
retribution when they were off-duty
things again pretty bad in this
alternate version of Earth but we'll
learn more about this probably this
summer at Comic Con the fall premiere
date is probably going to be sometime
either at the very end of August maybe
September maybe as late as October but
around that time of the year let me know
what you guys think about this I think
it's gonna be a pretty badass series
Watchmen is one of the best comic books
of all time it's perfect for HBO just
because it's such a hardcore story this
will not be the CW's watch
so you don't have to worry about any of
that kind of stuff what will happen is
is obviously there's a whole bunch of
Game of Thrones stuff happening this
weekend so I'll be posting more bonus
videos leave all your requests in the
comments below while you wait for
everything click here for my Game of
Thrones season 8 episode 5 trailer video
and click here for that brand new
spider-man far from home scene thank you
so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
you